what is your purpose what is your
mission with this business you have to
be unafraid the fact that you will fail
from time to time they have a knack for
something and you have a passion for it
that makes life a lot easier
may not love your neighbor but you sure
want to do business with your neighbor
what makes a successful leader
persuading others sharing a vision
sharing hardship earning trust
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from Forbes
editor-in-chief Steve Forbes and my take
on his top ten rules of success remember
one is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best
and as always as you're listening if
something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down in the
comments below and put it in quotes so
that other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
what is your purpose what is your
mission with this business and if you
have a purpose then money money will
come if you achieve that purpose and so
if you're good at a certain business
good at a certain product or service
that's your purpose in life go go pursue
it and you'll do a lot more good than
doing something where you don't have
that particular ability free markets
free markets is about people and trying
to do things with each other and if you
don't try to use the power of the state
to achieve success then you succeed you
no reason free markets are moral is
because you succeed by meeting the needs
and wants of other people if you don't
you don't succeed so even if you're that
Hollywood caricature of just loving
money and the kind of nasty personality
that makes babies crying dogs bark at
you when you go down the street you're
not going to get money well unless you
provide something somebody else wants
what's the difference between us and
people of the Stone Age basic difference
is we have more knowledge that's the
basic difference even if you suffer
physical catastrophes tsunamis Wars if
knowledge is not destroyed you can come
back again rebuild and move forward and
knowledge comes from constant
experimentation with Thomas Edison
called trial and error
that's why out in the world you have to
be unafraid the fact that you will fail
from time to time it's never a smooth
path and you'll be jostle you'll get
crisis you didn't anticipate it's part
of learning and also failure does not
mean nothing good comes from it none of
you are old enough to back in the 80s
and 90s Apple came out with a new
product late 80s early 1990s called the
Newton was a handheld device it flopped
in the marketplace but the technology in
that failure laid the basis for Steve
Jobs in the future
the ipad/iphone/ipod what we might call
it noble failure learning from what
doesn't work experimentation searching
of your entrepreneur who's done
something well money means you've
provided a product or service that other
people want so you're getting their
resources in return and it's not a
matter of having more than three meals a
day or five meals whatever satisfies you
right it's how you reinvest those
resources like Warren Buffett long ago
he had more than he could ever use in
terms of a material sense but by
reinvesting smartly increasing capital
he made it possible for pension funds to
increase in value shareholders to have
increased value companies to be able to
expand how do a lot of people get rich
in Hollywood movies you do it by killing
your customers polluting water and all
that kind of thing
but in the real world it's often having
faith in the future
putting together teams have worked
together and you take it you you're the
last one that gets rewarded you how to
pay your workers pay your suppliers keep
your creditors happy your financier is
happy and then if it works then you get
something but otherwise your your your
last in line and one of the things about
we discuss in the book about free
markets is contrary to Hollywood imagery
most novels imagery including occasional
yep scott Fitzgerald that's something
that a chip in the shoulder is that in
terms of free markets does develop faith
in the future he did not faith in the
future you would just be living for the
moments and so it does bring about
reduces variously humanity what is it
you are trying to do and if you remind
yourself of what is it you're going to
you're trying to do especially in the
business world where things are so
changing so rapidly if you remind
yourself of what your goal is then you
don't get quite as upset or disoriented
when the means or the tools to achieve
that goal
change well everyone has a knack for
something it doesn't mean you're going
to if you're in love tennis does mean
you're going to go to Wimbledon or you
have a knack for a software riding
you're going to become Bill Gates or
something but if you have a knack for
something and you have a passion for it
that makes life a lot easier where a job
actually doesn't just mean meeting the
needs of life but something you look
forward to each day something where you
feel you have a purpose you're doing
something well that that does a the it
gives you the intangibles that makes
life just more than looking for the next
weekend may not love your neighbor but
you sure want to do business with your
neighbor and we take it for granted not
to digress too much in the question but
we take it for granted in this country
that if you start something you want to
get the best piece of people possible
you can get as much talent as you can
and that's fairly new in human affairs
was until very recent times you trust
anyone beyond your immediate family or
your village or ethnic group just
couldn't do it
but commerce does break down those
barriers and have people interact in
ways that wouldn't have happened
otherwise and we see it in the global
economy we have today hugely complex
supply chains how did you develop your
understanding of economics and economic
policy just a fascination with it
economics is people markets people when
they talk about impersonal markets
that's usually code for you don't like
what people are doing and so how do you
have systems going back to our founders
Alexander Hamilton Ben Franklin and
others we all have innate ambitions
energies some good not some not so good
so how do you channel these innate
energies in a way that is constructive
that is not zero-sum that's what
commerce is all about your successes
other people's success in terms of
leadership itself while times and
circumstances change human nature does
not change
the essence of leadership the
characteristics that make for success in
failure or success leading you into
failure those characteristics do not
change what makes a successful leader
persuading others sharing a vision
sharing hardship earning trust those
things remain the same my one lesson
I'll give you today on facts about today
the world especially now needs a global
currency stability standard measure of
value do you ever find yourself in an
airplane you want a little bit of elbow
room start talking your seatmates about
monetary policy
yoyoyo you'll have all the room you want
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Arthur Robinson
Jr asked me to is there someone you like
me to profile in the next top 10 check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I'd also love to know
what was your favorite message from this
video what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to beau
Hawkins beau thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and posting the review on Twitter I
really really really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
for example cellphones or hangouts where
we call them today so the first one 30
years ago these are shoeboxes I revived
40 minutes first one out of view of
Motorola $3,995 today they're everywhere
they do everything except maybe grow
here every time everyone can afford a
set of vision around the world whole
world is now at your fingertips we're so
spoiled that we call mom going it takes
more than five seconds we say what a
lousy service is to this reason but
these kind of miracles become
commonplace entrepreneurs are allowed to
do great things we all benefit from it
but Lincoln talked about the opportunity
to improve our lot in life actually
makes this country great it doesn't
matter where you're from what you've
done before you can do great things if
the message is true if we can really
have our wishes if dreams do come true
and there certainly isn't they get up
every day and go do something they don't
enjoy with people they don't respect for
money that's not sufficient what would
be their first step toward going from
where they are to where they want to be
well if they have the opportunity is to
step back and say okay if I had a blank
sheet of paper what would I be doing
each day and don't say nothing because
that's the hardest job in the world
figure out what you have passion for and
being willing to apply the discipline to
achieve that passion when we go to a
sporting match for example we see the
end result of people many people who
have done a lot of sweat a lot of
training a lot of passion to achieve
their abilities but we don't see all the
work that goes behind the scenes so if
you're not prepared to do the grunt work
the scut work the discipline and that's
why it's often said people who have
worked hard to in terms of a discipline
way end up being freer than those who
don't have to do anything because then
they can't do anything number of years
ago a film named George Mitchell
in Texas had a natural gas company not a
big one you notice something that
everyone else noticed and that is this
country is running out of natural gas so
I asked his engineers can't we find a
way to get it out of the shale they have
a lot of shale tons of shale around the
world so what can we get it out and the
engineers said no way just not
economical and he pushed it he put his
own money into research and ultimately
the breakthrough came and now we're
drowning in natural gas natural gas is a
2 or $3 in Europe it's 12 $13 per
million thermal units and the amazing
thing is thousand keep amazing thing is
it's not only means we're going to cheap
energy again not only in a few years
will we be exporting energy in a major
way the government doesn't stop it not
only does that mean we're not going to
have we're going to have less diesel
which is not great for the environment
and be able to do trucks on natural gas
but also change the geopolitics in the
world when the biggest natural gas
produces up to now has been Russia they
have Western Europe as they say by the
short hairs
because Western Europe's depend on a
natural gas big chunk of it comes from
Russia
well natural gas is easy to get and
cheap then there goes Russia's leverage
there goes the Middle East leverage
because myths Energy's everywhere if he
are allowed to find it so one
entrepreneur whose name nobody knows
today outside of the energy industry is
profoundly changing lives this year
because of the fracking American
households are going to spend 12 billion
dollars less on natural gas to heat
their homes this winter than they would
have if Mitchell hadn't invented come up
with the eanes engineers come up with
fracking so and it's just beginning
it's just beginning